Where.
Like birthing yes.
It's hard to go home. Birthing was
another aspect of this vision.
I mean we were really looking
at. Cradle to the grave.
And so women were.
Dissatisfied with the present with
the situation as it was then.
They wanted to birth their children in a.
In a loving nonclinical atmosphere.
They didn't want birthing to be considered
a case for hospitals. It was really a.
To be seen as a natural thing. And in many
cases there was no need for hospitals.
I mean it was still recognized
that hospitals had their place.
If something went wrong. So.
So home birthing became
very strong movement here.
Run by women who are having children
and those women as they
their children grew up
or their energies went somewhere
else were replaced by other women
and that's continued to this day.
So that's birthing then education.
I think i mentioned earlier that
we started the community school.
People were really
concerned with education
that children weren't being educated
in the broad enough. You know in a.
Non regimented.
More flexible way.
And so we set up our own schools and.
We also started to see
the whole of all the
activities in the area
as part of our education
and our children's education
it was a sort of a.
A university of life.
And so people would hold workshops
and people would visit each other's
places to learn different crafts.
We were probably a little earthier then
than we are now. It was very much.
Back to the land. And while that's
still a very strong element.
Now there's a lot of diversification
and a lot of other interests as well.
So there was education the
university of life in the field.
Practical sort of learning.
I've lost the thread.
What else can i tell you.
Right right. Ok ok.
Yeah.
So another aspect of of the
values was the way we live.
What sort of houses we lived in.
You know how we did our gardens
and how we integrated
outside with inside so.
Because of the economic
circumstances. Much as anything else.
There was a whole range
of innovative ideas
that flowed into the building
the field of building.
And people were very
conscious of passive solar
design use of.
Benign materials materials
that were ecologically sound.
And use the lot of recycled materials
things that were at that time.
Very much undervalued. You know.
Buildings would get demolished
and the timber would get burnt.
So people put together houses
using a whole range of these
different materials.
People build houses that
were open plan and.
A lot of use of lofts.
Lots of verandas borrowing from
traditional straight in country style.
Lots of use of. Alternate energy.
Many of these houses were located on
properties that were way off the grid.
So there's no power no water. No services.
So people began to. Use.
Solar panels with battery banks.
For their 12 volt systems to power
their lights and their sound systems
and so on. Solar hot water.
They used wind power.
Many of the properties were
located in the in the foothills
around the mountain ranges
around the forested areas.
And they became in a sense the
protectors of the forest.
Such as at the rainier.
Anyway these properties were ideally
suited for water park because
there'd be streams running
out of these rainforests.
Which never dried up. And so if
you put a pelton wheel into them.
You could harness hydro power.
And so they then use
that as their energy source.
This such a variety.
You know there are domes ferro some and.
Nestling in forests
that sort of look somewhat like
mushrooms there are organic.
And the years of thane
them with. You know.
Moss and stuff and they
blend in beautifully.
I mean i'm particularly keen
about recycling cereals.
Often with in the case of timber the
recycled materials better than anything you
can buy now. All the best
trees were cut years ago
and.
There's the timbers really
good quality season.
And very strong.
Our local hardwoods terrifically strong
then then there's all the cabinet making.
Timbers.
Which you can selvage of fallen logs red
cedar for instance you can still find red
cedar lying around.
That was cut years ago.
A favourite house very difficult
to actually pick something out.
I haven't thought of it in those terms.
So that's why doesn't the doesn't come
thing i'm sure there is one but i.
I just can't think of it. As a feat.
Well i mean there are been amazing house
building feats in terms of just getting
things built.
There's a little stone cottage at thunderball
which is built on top of a cliff
and every stone
and every piece of material
was brought up by flying fox.
That that was a real feed and it was
built by a woman a frail not free.
I shouldn't call her frail
but a slightly built
young woman build a pole
frame construction on.
The relatively steep hill sides
with poles that are seven
or eight metres long. You know.
So it's sort of three storey
split level construction.
Amazing energy. To put these things up.
And to have had the guts to stick with it
and actually get it built because most of
these people have no previous building
experience. They become. They become very.
Multi-skilled on the land. You
know there's so much to do.
There are so many manual. Ask you you
learn very quickly to handle to.
And and improvise and.
So there's been a lot of that.
Yes many great feats of building.
Oh yes many of these building. Well.
Well i mean there are buildings
that aren't finished
that were started 18 years
ago. And are growing.
I mean this is another aspect of of this
style of building it's it's organic it
grows and it's fluctuates
according to needs.
You know the it might start
off with a single person.
Who then becomes a couple and you
know so they have to add extra space
and then children come
along and more space and.
And they discover more and
more about their environment
and their immediate surroundings.
So things get modified
and improved to take advantage of the
north easterly breeze the winter sun
sort of things.
So many buildings are gone for many years.
I think very few are
ever built. Full stop.
You can only do that with a
brick veneer you can't do
that with the sort of buildings
we're talking about.
This.
Well you know i realize
that it's sort of.
I realise that it's 20
years now since aquarius.
But that in itself is just a date.
I mean things have been moving
and changing all the time
and will continue to do so. So.
The vision that we had in
those early years in the 70s.
I think in many ways has been
fulfilled though not precisely as we
thought you know things are always changing
the state of flux of growth of learning.
And.
I see the next 20 years as a
continuation of that same process
but i see the celebrating.
I actually don't think.
Contrary to you might hear all
sorts of things about an ember
and one of the things is that nothing's
happening here. Well you know.
I i i have my finger on.
A lot of things happening in
that sort of poll seven in there are no
there are a lot of things going on in all
all sorts of directions.
You know alternate energy rainbow power
companies going from strength to strength.
And you know the future is
you know alternative energy.
I know the mainstream is still
hooked to non-renewable resources.
But it's having to confront
you know the difficulties
that are facing us that
are coming ahead and.
So people like the rainbow power
company are becoming more
and more relevant to the
mainstream. And so.
There are all the. These aspects of our
lifestyle here that are still developing.
There has been no full stop.
Nothing has really been achieved.
And therefore you can put aside everything
is still continuing and growing
and evolving.
Well.
I don't know if that's appropriate to
say because most of us in the beginning
that beginning wave weren't
teenagers. We were in fact.
You know early 20s on to late 30s.
And so a lot of us have
have reached middle age in.
You know now getting longer to and.
But i hope not. We are of life.
And a lot of kids have now grown up here.
And while many of them. Leave nimbin.
They take away the spirit
of nimbin and the values.
And the sort of aquarian values.
And many of them come back.
Many of us middle aged ones also leave
and go to other places.
And we hear of friends all over the place
doing similar things to what they were
doing here. But. Often.
Often now in the mainstream
people in government departments.
Yes.
In various community organisations
basically all still moving in the
same direction still looking for
alternatives to the dominant
paradigm.
Which is you know which is failing us and
and so they're looking for
alternatives that they have a dance of
that failure is everywhere
about us. And i think.
So i see nimbin as continuing
to pursue these concerns
environmental
and energy schooling birthing recycling.
You know we've set up a recycling
centre in the village.
We're very concerned with
waste management in general.
We're going to keep on
evolving community structures.
You know we've got a thriving artist
artistic community here we've got the school
of arts with the hall.
Many many musicians many
painters craftspeople
all of those things are
continuing to be developed.
And i think as as the the world economic
and environmental crises.
Becomes more apparent.
So the mainstream will look more
and more to places like nimbin.
For the solutions.